a 69 year old woman was punched in the
face at a North Carolina Donald Trump
rally arrest warrants went out for two
men accused of assaulting not only the
69 year old woman but also a number of
protesters and not only was the 69 year
old woman punched in the face she
happens to be Shirley Teeter a 69 year
old woman who carries an oxygen tank
around
she told the citizen times that a man
punched her in the jaw after she told
people leaving the rally you better
learn to speak Russian referring to
Donald Trump's very positive comments
about Russian President Vladimir Putin
this elderly woman was sucker punched in
the face by a trump supporter what's not
deplorable about this hashtag deplorable
so Titor later told
WLOS that she has protested several
times in her life she decided to protest
the Trump rally because she ran into
another situation that was sickening to
my heart what's going on with the
assaulters well Asheville police said
yesterday that an arrest warrant was out
for Richard Campbell an arrest warrant
was out for Thomas vilantae jr. and as
of I don't know a half hour ago
Valenti had turned himself in no word on
Campbell that I was able to find so far
if you look at the comments online about
this story and please don't eat anything
before looking online at the comments
about the story because it's pretty vile
way too many people are defending the
actions of those who punch this woman by
saying hey she was there protesting how
is this considered a legitimate response
to protesting a constitutionally
protected and I argue completely
American action to take protesting now
legitimately opens one up to being
punched in the face since when does
making America great again involve grown
men punching senior citizens and what
does it say about Donald Trump that
supporter after supporter thinks the
best way to support your candidate is to
physically attack people with different
political opinions and I am convinced
Rachel that this will be reflected in a
hypothetical Donald Trump presidency
there is no way that this
level of violence and vitriol and
supporters saying wrong opinion I now go
to physical violence in some way this is
going to be reflected if Donald Trump is
president right and I kind of think that
their supporters are actually
championing what they're kind of being
scolded for because surely Teeter had
asked them are you really deplorable as
now and then there were many people who
were showing up to his rallies wearing
shirts that said I yes I am deplorable
so it kind of makes me think that it
would be illustrative of how his
supporters would act if and when he were
to be elected yea which hopefully won't
happened but yes they've tried to take
the power back of this oh we were
insulted as deplorable --zz will show up
with our deplorable shirt and show them
who's really deplorable and that's sort
of exactly what they've done here and
for a very long time these Trump rallies
seem to bring out what is absolutely the
worst and many people some will of
course write this off as just an
isolated incident it has nothing to do
with Trump's policies or his supporters
more broadly it's just some isolated
incidents unfortunately that's bogus
this does tell us a lot about the entire
base that Trump has coalesced it
probably too much about that we've
covered that extensively we covered it
yesterday in our long-form
expose about Donald Trump and yes any
individual incident could be just that
an isolated incident but all too much
these incidents are happening number one
at Trump rallies number two against
people who seem to have the wrong
opinions and number three in ways that
are and it's amazing that we are using
this word in ways that are absolutely
deplorable in what they say about these
individuals I've talked about how people
of all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is Zipcar which
gets you a car when you want it when you
need it
they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your zip
card each car share member reduces their
personal co2 emissions by between 1100
and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join Zipcar
comm slash david support our show reduce
your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars
sign up at join zip car comm slash David